how's it going guys welcome to the
broken podcast I said it right yay I'm
here with cinnamon toast Ken as always
yes
someone actually came on our show Emma
blackery Wow oh my god why did I
volunteer for this well basically we
told you we want to do a quiz saying
what youtuber would date you and you
were like well obviously I'm gonna go on
that that's definitely it you definitely
didn't tell me after I'd already agreed
Felix who would you want to date you
from YouTube who's your dream date ooh
can I can i suck on that one a little
bit yeah oh yes you can
this is Swedish how do you say in
Swedish - sooo gap but I lit that at
that oh yes you can't answer is that we
we know have not see this otherwise
let's hear she's not a sandwich all
right okay is that another Swedish term
let's go on with it Chris Jesus cried
you question one hey everyone sir if
this sucks
it's not a question that is the question
yeah the possible answers are hey and
it's fine and second one is sure no
problem laughs I think that's the Joey
Graceffa one always good to say that I
don't know if I want to know um ah the
third one is whatever yes Dan that's Dan
Howell real or maybe okay maybe you I
don't know
don't spoil it sorry I wanna know Josh
I don't know don't ruin this
okay I'm personally and forth one yeah
can we get on with it
any brackets it as me okay pushy what
the [ __ ] this I don't know it's not this
is true only one the last one is it's no
issue so there'll be someone really
chill well I'm gonna answer this as to
like you know what I would say instead
of like trying to guess who is from
because I just ruin so quizzically Felix
so if someone start off a video hey
everyone sorry if this sucks
I would be mad about it because that's
what I hate the most
oh hey guys thanks for watching my video
really sorry if it's a terrible video
and I want to bring your expectations
down first thing so self-deprecating
yeah can't we get on with very I'm sorry
that my syringe is out of place today my
things don't look too great
I'm sorry I'm sorry chick isn't great my
colored hairs a little off today so I'm
sorry this video wasn't that interesting
and please like it haha
I'm sorry sorry this is just a chatty
video we don't [ __ ] make it if you're
not sorry about it no [ __ ] uploaded
there [ __ ] chaos yeah so I guess I
probably say hey and it's fine
what would you guys say yeah can we get
on with that yeah can we get on with it
Oh
final I can't we have ma are here for
contrast now yeah we always pick the
same thing it's so boring
Oh question number two don't worry buddy
okay so what's your favorite color
husband dan dan oh face I know it's sad
howl but why
good lips like this okay the first one's
blue get off my man and me I like you
whatever it was me
is it me I don't like the best here at
the quiz I think Oh God
I think that's for some my fanfiction to
this soon like this is I was like 12 and
had innocent messenger orange with a
little pleased face green with just a
period sky blue
and then add note from the author says
chill chill and then none of these okay
ariana.sea
Phil I don't know just kissing a little
face the Donna I don't know what is my
favorite color a lot of those in my
favorite colors lucky these lilies leave
me all be the same I think so man I'm a
yellow kind of person myself I have
joined us I later black like my soul
okay well that's good to know
favorite food everything meat still it
like you the [ __ ] I mean I don't you
spend ah it hurts
ah it hurts ooh Chinese Chinese takeout
what's the difference yeah say Mary ah
well I guess it's kind of difference I a
Chinese buffet or something but there's
kind of the same just depends where I
read it
shitty what's also if it's great
actually and rice not sassy much also
they wrote I don't know anything I can
get my hands on that sounds like a hobo
question
what do you spend your time doing and
the first one is me yes you just a
million exclamation marks and the author
says ok you need to chill so it's a
message to you dude you need to chill
yeah sure now I agree with that the
author and uh second one is making
parodies which which I can presume would
be Shane Dawson
number three is being a sarcastic [ __ ]
or [ __ ] you're right that sounds like
Felix - hmm me am I gonna date myself
I'll go videogames well I am genuinely
kind of sarcastic 12 so I'm gonna give
it on okay good I'm glad you're honest
at least I'm trying I mean this is you
know I don't want to I don't want to get
this quiz wrong this is very important
but it was smart
the first one is this cackling happy
face made with the D and then the next
one's a winky face and then the next
one's a pac-man face the next one's the
closed eyes face like squinching up so
hard and os was just a pleasant smile as
soon as she said the one that was made
with D I clicked on that one oh yeah yes
sir
can your daddy didn't even look at the
others well you sold it to me in this
field that I'm just gonna click the
winky face all right it's go like a
panini in his mouth [ __ ] do you want
one one one one pretty one three one
pretty why pretty why like what's the
point of the quiz then if they're just
gonna ask us they just ran out of
questions clear clearly seven is just
too much
alright first one is down is on fire me
up me up top sister Oh [ __ ] rule they
put this question just so they could
have another chance to the four Simonis
jacksgap number two beer too bad I'm
guessing that's how they do it because
they have like a million exclamation
marks afterwards Shane Dawson or amazing
film mmm I hate all these people
especially the third one okay
we're not gonna pick you so eat as well
come on one way to me me we're not going
to eat you and I any friends of one of
those people
I'm gonna go amazing fell you know I'll
go with Shane all right
a pig's PD once again I get a pressing
question this is uh okay the question is
three three three
you